-Ні, не ви. Не ви!
Ваша організація жахлива.
- Звідки Ви?
- Бі-Бі-Сі
- Якщо вже ви нападаєте на нас,
ви дозволите нам поставити питання?
Пане обраний президенте,
якщо ви нападаєте на нашу новинну організацію,
ви можете дати нам шанс?
- Ні ні. Я не збираюся давати вам право ставити питання. Ви робите фейкові новини.
Журналісти в США зазнають гострої критики з боку президента.
Трамп намагається змусити журналістів замовкнути,
погрожуючи тим, що вони нестимуть відповідальністю за свої слова.
Для репортерів Білого дому настали важкі часи.
Ми маємо боротися за наше право залишитися в прес-центрі,
ми маємо боротися за право працювати на "Борту номер один"
і супроводжувати Президента під час ділових поїздок.
Знову і знову Дональд Трамп повертається до журналістів спиною:
у квітні він відхилив запрошення на щорічну вечерю кореспондентів Білого дому,
на якій традиційно присутній президент.
Зі свого аудиторією Трамп найохочіше спілкується через твіттер -
оминаючи у такий спосіб традиційні ЗМІ.
І якщо Трампу не подобається,
як його діяльність висвітлюють журналісти,
він зганяє свої емоції в соціальних мережах або під час виступів.
Ми боремося з фейковий новинами.
Це підробка, фальшивка, фейк .
Він називає фейковою новиною кожну історію,
яка йому не подобається.
Таким чином він намагається приховати інформацію,
яка виходить не від нього, а від інших джерел -
державних або інших організацій.
Трамп називає цю інформацію демонстративно "підробкою",
що посилює недовіру з боку наших читачів
і підриває репутацію нашої професії.
Журналісти з Асоціації кореспондентів Білого дому
висвітлюють діяльність президента вже понад сто років.
І для Джеффа Мейсона зараз немає нічого важливішого за його роботу.
Адже саме він захищає права журналістів і стежить за тим,
щоб його колеги могли виконувати свою роботу у Вашингтоні.
Цього року Deutsche Welle
нагородила Асоціацію премією "За свободу слова",
якою нагороджуються люди та ініціативи,
які борються за свободу слова і права людини в усьому світі.
У США свобода преси перебуває  під загрозою,
тому що глава держави нападає на вільну пресу,
ЗМІ та журналістів, часом переходячи на особистості.
На мій погляд, це неприпустимо.
За світом треба спостерігати,
і це наша робота.
Ми вдячні за цю підтримку,
адже ми не лише стаємо на захист свободи преси в США,
але підтримуємо свободу ЗМІ в усьому світі.
Незважаючи на тиск з боку Білого дому,
Джефф Мейсон і його колеги налаштовані і далі здійснювати свою роботу -
повідомляти про факти і ставити важливі питання.